bien alors maintenant chez vous vous
éteignez la lumière et je réponds à
laurent asti pas la télé je suis un mec
qui me dit quand on fait la question qui
tue on éteint la lumière mais ce qu'on
doit éteindre la télé non on éteint que
la lumière laurent est ici aussi
voilà c'est chaud là c'est luis
hernandez
serez-vous encore entraîneur du psg la
saison prochaine
jusqu'à preuve du contraire oui même si
vous perdez tous les matches qui
viennent là je ne souhaite pas perdre et
je pense qu'on ne perdra pas tous les
matches qui restent
on va en gagner on va remonter on va on
va se resituer dans une position qui
sera un peu plus honorable pour le
parlement et pour tous ceux qui aiment
le pas et sam
merci on rallume bien
prochain match que maintenant vallée
sous entend plus les matchs du psg
prochain match le 3 mars et j'ai
toulouse et la corogne le 7 mars donc on
sera tous devant le poste de télé pour
vous soutenir
ouais il faut